C Y>>OUCH WANATHE TES RT OFHE T
BO, .OTVRG FARSECHVE SORTE
SOUP ORITHE T T TLEHE
ATDICT OSHORIPF WFOLIT CAP.AL
G USINEAETH SOXHRC B TT AHEOP T
OF TE. PHEAG
..
>>DANO T CUT TOUHRGH
TINVCOENISALON WMO THE T NEW
WANDF O UDISTERAN ONGFOW H
TH
LD WEOR.OR WKS
NE TOR YKESESIM BINSET-LL
GAU
FORTH OOOIX S BKS AND
CODEUNR OFUS PH CAN
RIDUINSTTA CESONPA CCTOMESNI
ROATTH PCEDUS-WWA ARDNIINNG
ASPODCTOR FIG IND
OUENS
ORHIST
RRI WTEHET A TOREW N YRKE
1NCSIEND698 A PSLVIREOUY
COODRE TWAHE T "ONINSHGT
PO N F"OR ARLEAY DADECE.
MLCMAOLSEL DVE IEE DPONT
ONESQUTIUT ASBOOLEC THNNDYOG A
BETINT IENSSON A TYHE
ELLCOIDHA TTLA EXP OTINAON
F
ETHESSHE TMEHEN I TOS MT
CENTNEA SSOISF O H PCAODST
HES PUTOG T THEETRHEESTO SRI
TOFHESEN GIUT THA IEM HOMEAD
ERMPCOUT HAN, DIL FISAMY IN
AABALAMND AHE TNO TMI EXANE
ORETH MALLL CHAGEENSF OER MODN
AM HICERAN.TOISRY
ND>> AH WITNE O OFUR O
TEVOFARIUEST
SNDA IUTHE T AFRHO OIX SOO BKS
AB
USTOU B AESINSAN HNDUM
BE
IVIHAORNGLUNCDI NTH "E
ES TRKIM"ELES BTSRLE HE IS AWYO
TGREARIEN AND WENO CANT
WAO HTIM H ANDIS H
UP
MICONGOOK.
HEIN TGR PROEAM WIL WLAK TE
FMESO OOU YR QNSSTUEIO
S CUANMIUBTHE TMNG USIHE T
Q&UT BN.TO
TH A IES LKINO TCH PUREAS
ONDIADTIIE CALOP T ISN CT
BO
>> ANDS A WEDAL WKE ONAL MLMCO
ANDAN DNT IOR YOUOM HE.
>> .
>> ODGO TO SEEOU Y.
>> ATWH AAT GREAR P OTF
INWASHONGT DCY MME FOR
R
TOHOME Y IWNNR SMPING
SOUGRND SDAIDE IAS INHE T CYIT
MECO ITAN CNO WTAIIL UNT WE
CATUO D S IFFERN PN.SO
RWEHOVEOOHE T GS NDEW ISHA TT
AVWE H PEPLEOEDRO AUNHE T
TRCOUN N IYFROOT A TDUNHE
DWORLO TAK T TETHAAG MIC THE
ROLEOP FAS TMEXND A NEW
.XIMECO
VE CSOONNATRSIO
IT WH
GNOW,L.DWLAEL
WEE HREERO TK AHEUTBO T
BOER M
IAAF.
OUSERIY.SL
SISTH IAT G ARE RD.EA
EO SOYNJEDNGEA RDIS THI
OKBO.
IEA LRNET SOMNGHI ANDHI TS IS
AT GAREEA RD ILL REANJY EEDOY
IT
.
BUTHIS DN'IDTTA SRT OFFO T
EABE R IDTTA S TEDRTO
BE
D.HEAR
NOOLYAL G PRO FMONTRI T
AU THA YOUT WENRO F AMIOUD
TO
NT PRI
A ULLSHAUTBO T
G IOTNT IOS THIOP T WICNHE
IOIAS DNG MYAS LT
RE
ISSIVIONTO HTIS.RY
DAN IZEEA RLID AS I WASOI DNG
CA PMYOD ISTAM BECERE V
Y
REINTENEDST I SUD AIO -RETA
-
STLIYTOREL.NG
HEDAN TMSIR CCU UNCTAESERND
TICWHH AREHE'SRET BTEOAY W T
TERY S ATO
T WISASHT RHEIGAY WO TLEL
TH SRYTO.
TANDAKTHA TROE F TMHEECON
DWORLAR W.
REEES AHE TWO TESIG FUR.
>> DAN TNHEOU YE HAVO T HREA
WH ARENGOM BBIAC ATT
KS
DSSOUN AIK LEOND T HREAHE T
OICVOES TFHEIC VMS AND
SO IINTHGER PSOWBOLFU A
UTTE
TINLLGRY SHETON IUD AIO
UTRMFO BSHA TT'RE WHE I BANEG
IHEEOV T AOKIOUDBO.
LSTBU A AOS A PNT BK.OO
BU
TOR SO LGONRY STOSLLTEER
HACTEG NLE A TEDHEORIOUD F
M
HEOF TIRTO SESRI.
ANHE TYAV HEOC FEDUS UULNDY
ON
HERINTE. PEDAG
>>LYTAERINEGHE T B ONIINNGF
STITSIE WAN HHUM
C ATILIVIZEN,IO W
DIE H'TAV T W AAY
IZRIMOALSE TEHONPO SKEOR WDS
TOEX TT.
WNOWE HEAV AACK T TOHE
ORETU TMIRA TNSRI STTO IESN
ER PAOWLFUAY W.
ARHE T'S DFERE STOESRI IN
INPRT?
WNOT THA IEE DONIX S
ONSEAS A OSFOD PSTCASLT AER
TH
WEAY I WTERI.
SO HOREFE SERTTAEDOI DNG THE
ASPODCEV IT N WLDE HAV
NITWRTE KHI TSFDIN OTO S IRYN
TH
I WEAY WTEROHE TRY STO.
SO
WHE TAY I AMRI W INGTIS
HEYILOR INFDME TTHA'V IEOW N
TSPENEAIX S YNG DRSOI A
POT.AS
S IITSDPOUPSEEEO T FL
SANVCOERONALND A ITEEDMMIA.
TH WAY IPP A CACROHERRAHACT
AN
D PTLO AND DAIL ITS I SO
IN
EDUEFLNC.
ITARD TOES DIBCRE I
TOUTHGHT A THENIEG BINNGT I
WAYIM SPLEWORKERS.IE PCE
ITSO S NOT
HA TT.
AIT'SPL COM DELETYNTFEIFRE
ALANIM.
ATY M FSTIRCERO PDUR WHO
EOKTO MY B THEAN H ADNDTAU TGH
HMEOWO TL TEL ATORYN I
UNSOD.
>>NTST' IESTI BEC ISEAU
CAHEO T T PNTRIOO BK NOT
INHEAR P AGNYCAODSTPI EDESO.
AN THERT SNHOTE SERENNEESNC O
WORDNCEN STEAN, ESTRSTISION SO
DO
AVOU Y H AERERE PFEOENC D
YOUT WANEEO PPL TONIS LTE TO
ATHERIOUD OEA R TDHE PNTRI
OK?
EYTHAN COW D TOANLDHE
AU
KOBDIOOR B THERI PNT
BO
.OK
A LF OT THA DENEPDSN O
YWHATROURERE PFE
ESNC.
ETHERIDRE A K WSHOEV NEREA RD
BOS BUTHE TYSU CONUGME H
E
ERNUMB A OSFOKIOUDBO
RT THANER PSO MYOM M DOE'T
LI A TENO ANOKIOUDBOHE S
NTWASO T RDEAHE THEN S SULD
ADRE A BK.OO
INKHI AS WTERIRSE WE HAV
BECO AGN ATIOSC TTHEM FOR
HEATTH TSU CYONME OUROR WKND A
WE
TEE NDODERO PVIM THE WHIT A
SE
FESRI O O.IOPTNS
OU YVA ELED THEOR FM OF
UDETH A IBOIOOK ITS MEORHA TN
SI
NELYMP ONER PSONGEA RDI A
TE
XT IONT AIC MEPHROONND
TVIHANGRATHA TEDMINSTTUT B
GT'LES TOO THE STSRYTO IF.EL
CI FAAS STINANG
RYTO.
LYREALEL WLTUTR SUCDREHE T
TFIRSAR PTF O THE BKOOAL T
KS
TABOUHE DAM THEON SEC
D
PA TBO AUTEMHE TNATPTIOND A
TH AHE TRE TREWO
TEESLONOGI AHA TT
RECH
RSACARTENHE TOO BK.
TE
A ULLSUTBOHO TSEWO T
LOCHTENONDESGI A WHE TNETE G
IOMENTD.NEERESLINATI YHA TT
>> FIRSTT I WASHE T BBOME SIT
WH
HIC THEEE THROR MAJ
TECALONOGITS FLEAHEF O T
SELD WNDOR TAR WHECAME ARI
NEF
HERTFO T WIR FST THET MOS
IVPEEXNSND AN THEHE T SONECD
WADAHE T A PMJEROCTHE T
CONDSTIG-BGEHEAS W T-2 B9
BO BERUTHE TRD THIAS W THI
LILENA AGLOTEOM CPU AR
ND-P55OUNIEC MHALCA DICEVE
WIUN A B OCH KNO ABSND
BUNDSON ACOYR GOSNDSPE A
PU
IEYLLSDENNTDEOLO T S AVE
MOBPRLE THA TTHEEDEV DIL
BOOWSER H YO DOUAK MEUR SE
ATTH AOM B LBDSANHE WRE ITS I
SUOSPPED TOAN LDT THAS I
NEINSALYCUIF DFI.LT
PTHEOENELA G 2 MILNES A
6HOUR IIL MESHEN T AIRHE T
LONDWI B AWSTMI 75 NSLE A HROU
ANEMHE T TRERAPETUILL
GECHANEG00 1 DROESRE F
TMHE
TPOINROOU Y DHEEDPP T BBOMO T
WH
TEER IANDS ONHE TRO GDUN
TH EEAROV MESN O ITSXI A ASSTH
TH
D BEONS IINRO DPPG CUDLO
RCOVE THEPL PEOTTE A YKIACNGOU
ARINHO SOTLE BGUL STOHE T ADA
CYOUROLDOU DP A BB UND
ER
ETHOSTION CDISONS I LICRO
SOHE TN TOOL S TVEHEEMRO PBL
EVEGI M AOU CUNEPL H
EDDR
IOMILLLA DNOL I ARSNDIL WL
ODUCE FOROU YHO T OANUSDSF
ONETH CONAPTRTIT TSHA
LL AW
TYOUHA MOECYCANILL ANT EERLL
OFHE TAR VBLIAES ANDHE T YNOU
CA IAN LD WTREHEOU YAN W TT
NDLA AT.
TANDONHE TEL H WPHITHE T
PO
LNTTEIAND TN Y ROULIEAZE
WA
IT AINUTUT BN THEHE T
ROTHEOLEC THNYOGS IAL NAPM
SOCIED WHEHIT TAMIE VTN
R.WA
NAS WOTTENV IENORD F VTNIEAM
JAPALI RNEANDZE IHE T93 10S
EREYTH WE MEAD UPHE T
TISBOERX'HEF O TOR WLD
CIES CONRUCTED OUTF O
WO
NDENOD APEAR TPASE HROU
SST
SDIANNG-SE-IDBYNEID O
NAEE SOWTR Y ITSF POUUT A
NHTC IHE TEID MDL OFT I THE
WHNG TEHIOU WLDO G UPN I
SAMFLES AOUP GROF O CMIHEST
ATVAARRDVE UNI TITRSY
O
UCPROD THEESRE GATTPO WEAN
AL NDAP IMS THEPP O
ITOSE
YIDEAL WOUILOT NROP A BBOM
WISIRE PCI Y BONUTOUIL WL
TOPDR IND AUR BN THE WLEHO
THN. DGOW
SOHOSEDEWO T I AASRE
ONAMCHPI BEDYFE DIFNTREEEO PPL
IN
AHE TIROR CPS ATHE T
BEGIINGHEF O TDEC SONLD WOR
WA
>>XA ELYCT.
THEEO PPLHO WIOHA CMPN
, THATETHOM BBIT S TEHEBE BOMR
MA
IAFIN A WAYER WEDEALTIC
TABOUINIG FHTAR WSND AO S
TE
ULLSBO AUTAY HOD.
ACCHARR.TESUCN A ANRIMECAND A
HES I A P-ER GEN
IOATNS
HESOUTIT MRNILAMYAR FYIL
GREAGRT-HEDFANAT A WRAS
GEHELRA TDEON CFETERARM A AY
ROICNTOE PYTRRI WNGTIIS H
VORIOV NEL ISAU BEC HSEE
FIENIDTIESIT WH THEIG N
HT
INTAPP T OGN WHEDOINWSY M
SRIVOTEE'RYTO HE GSON SOFA
ROCHMU F HISOM HEE LIF ONE
HTIMEEOM C HESEOMGAV HIN
WNNDIERISHIT HIF WE AND H
TARHESND SHEOU ANDAY S WSTHA
HAIS TT SHEAY S TSTHAOU YR SON
BTHEY WGRY CIN INHE T
ROTHE RM.
IHESHE TMP CHAFNIO O TSHI
.VIDECE
AELATRE B IVEIERN THEIS VNIO
L BED I ANBALAMAND AHE T
THTIIRESHA T YTOUO NGE LON
R
THAVEL KOILHO T OANUSDSR
HUFDSRE OANHO TUS ODSF
CI
SLIVIANN A CTFLONIC YOU
CO I UDSE JTTUS TOOM B
B
ETHOSALRU CCITSAR TGE
OU Y
EDNEEDO ORRUNR YOUNE E.MY
JU OAK TE TUT POWTSPLERAN
ANQUHE T A AUCEDTSNDHE T
RI.ES
ONUYO D HAV TOOYES DTR THE
WHEY CIT JTE TAKUT O THE
MI SRITALYCANIIGFINT
S.RGTAET
RI CHEART TESHAIO VISNTN I
O
STHE WONECDARLDOR WND A
CO TCEINS THEOPARIL MITY
BRS OFHE T MALORND A
CTERAGICTOR CREFSSNE O HIS
PO
TISIONAK T IESTGHHR TOU
AROEUPE TLLHEAY WO T JANAPO T
ARETH WIN AGASTAP J IANNHE T
WI
ERNT OF4. 4
SHE I AREA LDE OFHE T GUPRO
TH TAL CLSVEMSHEEL TSHE
MBBOERIA MAF.
>>EA R IDTS A AER V
LIIDEAICSTACPP AROHHA TAR
NNIS URYESECSA AHE TREAYRE WS
TOHECEOR T C'SNTOURY
GICHANNGHE TIR BRAVEHIO TOE B
IN
V AYERCI PREAY WHI T WSAS
AALAD RICA IDEOT NT JUS WE
HALI A S DTLGHYNTFEIFRE
STUTGYTE BTLM AOSNH URDEAF O
D LANEIK MNHY URDEAF OAS IDE
EDCOOKP UN I ATR S AGEANND
PUAUSLCELAN IMALA ABA BUTUN
SVEGI U AEN SSEF O HOW
LIEVPRAIT TNGHA. WAS
>> THENTON CVE MNAIOLYITILAR
THSNGKI IHEYEREOY TS AS
ANER AFTOUGH
HELLWI TROM BBEIA MAFAI S
D
ATHEY NREOTOY T TSYHE AREHE T
MOST INTORMPTAME ELENDNT AE W
TH
KIN AOD MNER BBEOMROU W BLDE
ANDOYES DTRTHVE ERYEGIN WEE ND
TO
OYES DTRIT WHNE EMY
ORRRTEIT
ADS AT,ES RULVE ERYTH OER
ENELEML WTILE B MEAD
LEOBSO.TE
'T DWEONEE ND THEAV NY ORHE T
MA
ONERIS TAN OR TOPROSR O
ERTIARLLAN IYNFOUY,TR YE NAM
IT
.
LAL GEON.
N TDHE -N O - AD BAN OF MEN
IN TIR TSNTWEIEND ART THISIE
DANOMON MTGYERMALA ABA
NGRSPUUIROND A P ATIMONG
RACAL IADE TTHAHE T
COALTIENONSTND UER ODIANNG
FMI
WTALIRYOECHHI GK BSAC
THNDSAS OFEA Y SRSINAYGT I
OVE IRT ISOL OBSEET.
T W>>HAS ICI FAS ATINANG IND
DI'TNO KWHIS IST THA AT
TH TIM,  AETHIRCE FORS I NOT
AEAREPATHRA BNCF OHE T
MITALIRY BLYICASALHE TY ARM
AHADEW FLA PSNEEN ESSALTILY.
Y>>ESHE TYE WER PACHING
THISNOT NIOM FROIT WNHIHE T
.ARMY
THER WE JIOUNR OSICFFERHO W
SA T TIDOHESS BRAN I VAGIIRNI
ANAS WNNGHITO DCOU YEN
WTHEIDNGRO SFE ORYIS HTO
.IT
AS W AOK JEOI GNGUN AROD
THATAI SD IFHE T AYRMNE KW
ATWHAS W HNGPEAPNI IN
MO WMEGORYLD WEOULL AE B
IN
.JAIL
[L
TEGHR]
ITHAT R HSOW IICADALTLL REA
YWA
HEUT B TA IDE WAST THA
CATERAGIYLLOU YT JUSOM BBT
INNARISCMIOULYTE Y
OU CLD
FIRE ATIG NHT IT'TOE DSN
EIERTT NURERTH DHEGIN T DAY
JYOUANTUS WOT T DPRO A LOTF O
BO A ASNDIEDFLA P ASCEND
WR
SKEA AUC MHAV HOC ASOU Y
CA
TH TER WEKIALNG AUTBOERY
OWNARRGE TARDTE BSBIOMNG B
TA
AINLKGREUTBO AABI BOMNGR
A
MALORE BBIOMNG.
>>DEHE I TATHAHE TYE WER
ROCONF WINNTGAS THEDE IAHA T
T
HWASDELY BT MOSON CNANTVEIO
LMI
TTALIRYSNKHIERHET A T TE.IM
ULUSEFFSSNE OOMHE T B WRBEAS
TO YUCEDEROU EMYNESIT CIE.
GONDN A BDON
NGYTERHI CKI, LLNSILIVIAO T
LIMODERAR YZEOUNEMY
TATTH'SEOTHA PHOEPL THTUG
GMBBOINORAS W F
IA MEAFDOO LKET AHA TT
STRAGY CTTEONMPERND A D
IN
OLIKEAL MURORR.OR HRO
EYTH TUGHOHT HOWOU C ALDNY
MOWAYLL AKEAN HUMNG BEIIT W
H
ILA MARITYEGTR SATYAS BED ON
THTR DEESTIUCON OFIL CIVNSIA?
>>OOW TYMB EODHA TAN, D
VHEOTRFWIE OOW H TOAG W AEN
WWAR AASON SECHAD CCTRAER
THOU YEN MONTIEDEF BRILY
NGRISTVIRO FM CTRENALTI CASNG
LL, TEBOS U AURUT CEMSTI L.AY
THENTIT ISIHESN ERYVE WAY
CHI THETYOV PERW GREP U IN
THTSTR SEE OFOL CBUUMS.
>>
DS AID I AS A MTER OF
FA
OM HOWETNER HO.
AL LOA RDS TDEAOALEN CTR
IOOH.
D>> I NIDOT TNO KWT.HA
GH[LAUR]TE
>> HEKS LOO LEIKVEAS MSI
SQ
EAREUA H HDEAS H AE HUG
TCHES A MAN A FEWOR WSDS IN A
STOVERTEMATEN SE HAKPES AND
BL
UTTUN GRATULRO GS.WL
SHE IHL RUTNSSES UNTTIENME
ALBL
HIDOO TNDTYRS AUTIT WHO
ENNSCOCICEE HNK THIHES T WAY
TOHTIG A WARS I TO BS A
ALBRUTNRND A UNGENELTI AS
IBPOSS B MLEAYE THEAT GRETES
NA TANTIACCI IFOU Y TKALO T
IRMAHON W SVEERDN I THE
EUANPEAT THENDER A Y AEDSK
HI
MHO W T'SHEESRE GAT TTOVE ER
SA WHE TY SLDOUAYHO WIT
TIESON THELO ANAGY IS LEIKQU
THBA A THEIN NIEETSOU Y
ULWOD SAYELIC MHADA JOR WNLEHI
HE TASHEIC MELHA JDAORN.
TANDHEEL UNRTIENNG AND
LYLUSOTEN O ITEERNTESDITH
ORETH MALIS DN.SSCUIO
AN THE TN KOLILS A MH OF
NEETH E AMYS I C.AN
OU YAN CNEMA IGIHE WN HE
ERSCDIOVAL NSAP H UMSOOAS C
DE
HEUP TAT GRETESEN INC IARDIYN
ISETH HRYTOF OAN M SOE H
OVDISCAPSER J IANS A CNTOURY
ITEDLL WPA THARRPE ANDOO WD.FI
THAT ALL IEE ND TONO KW.
I'OFF O THE TES RAC
.
>> IHA WTHTHO TUG IS
FAGATININ ISHE WNAL NAP
M
CAME TOE BHE W TNHEAN BDF O
RSOTBRHEN IBA ALANDMA A TNHE
SO INSANE CMIHEST TYHE
TE
EDST IT.
N TDHEHE TYATIM SULEDT. THA
DTHEY IIDN RLEAIF LE.
IHANDOU TTNAAS FCINGTI.
IHE TRES FOUAMSTERC AHICT>
USFAMOTERC AHI ICTN.AP JAN MT
AN
EL DDEVAL NOPAP AMNDHE TY
IDSA INHE TH UTAES D ITERN THE
TEINSTG GUNRODS TTHAAS W THE
TACEP RCALIND A THEO T
EILBUD ACTXALYY TSHERE A IN
JA
N.PA
B HSOE ALDUISGH NEIDRHBOOO.
TO
EHE TENXTT TOHICH TO
REATICE TOAK MET ICT EXAN I
NPA ANDHE TN WLD BUIHI TS
REHAAIC TNST' I THEES DTER
AN LHE TY ANCAUHND ATTKN O
TH
LA VEILH WGEIT NALM.
DTHEYLLPRO AHE T NALAPM
CAERSND THENHE TOTY NE
WHNSAP HPE
E HEYAV CHE TIR AERAMASND
ADEVIOIE MNDOVER CAMNDAS A
THEYAK TEES NOT INS BUROW DN
ANUIOW H Q ALYCKNDOW H TO
OENGLO D ISTE TAKHA W ITST LEF
THEND.
THVEBS OERHA TT NALAPM IS
TLRFPEECTE SYUI R FDORUCIN
JA
NEPASESIT CIEIT WNHIUT MINES
NK TIHIT' ISE FIVF I PESIOSBL
AN KHE TY AWNOT TTHAOI PNT
TH
T IISSTHAE WLD COUSE U
AGHETNS TAN JAPEESEO PEPL.
ASTHO: TSHERY STO
LDUNFO B TS,HEBEOMRIA MAF'S
SIVION'T ISNOR W ANGKISEL WL
IN
ICRA PCT AES ITID D IN
TH.RY
IR TSOHE AIM WASO TP DRO A
BOMBHATHE T WYEERES LS
TECUACRA THA TNNDTHA A IT
'TWASNNGOR WKIHALL A TL. WTEL
AND SO INIS H SEEHA TTS I
BRLIAN T ATTACHE BNDKEF OT I
TH ITIALDEISC SONF O THE
HUT ISCEEP RLAD BY ARE BARLO
DESCHTEHI OOHE W WNHOOM SE OF
US MHTIG RREMEMBE TOE B GRGEOE
WASEAC INGUN RNIAT M WENHE
HE
OAN RN THETIC TKE IN 18.96
IDPRESTIENALDAAN CDITECE VE
ACREPLDF HESAN T IULN
HE
FIPACI T ACNDSLSEL U WTHA
ENHAPP
HE TESAKISISDE IALCTI
VI T TONOHE PACICIFERHE TAT
GTEAFRSMUA ITU CAPMEDRE ACARI
IS CALINLYNOSELO EHUG TO
NJAPAHEND A TY ASKIM H TO
ANMMD ANDPE OTIRAON HEAK TES
A
FHO WLEETLEF OHE T 2 G92M
UITO B TLDHEIG B ISTGEN THE
WO T ADNDYHETART LNGNCAUHI
RA OSNAP J.AN
I STOAYIL WLOT NIL KL
JAIVSENE C AIAILNSNE BREUR
DDO
WNHE TNT COURY THELA P
NS
UTHEYODSE TUF MANTUACRE I
RWILL TUCEDEBIIRHE A TTYLIO
WA
F WGEARMRO THE AIRO T
THEMSEEF DENSSLESTGA AINNY A
OKINDICAMF ER.AN
ASSAT.UL
ASEGTR SATY STAITRGHUT O OF
MMBBOERNEIAAF O OHNE O.
HETHWI TOS MTIT MILYAR
GIRASTTEC T.GEARTS
RE TSOHES INE OSI MISER AFT
ROTANHE GRO FMMUA TAN JAP.
HEDAN TD SNAI ITOE D D'TSNO
WHUPT I SSEPOD TOO D HE
RES DLYOEVEEL BIEF IE' HS
GIUG ENNOE THIME HAN C
NGFACIE TLLHEEMRO PBL HSES I
HI WATAS ITONGNAT ISMPNTIE
OANDNE DAYE HETSP U AND
ITIS A VORITRO FMHI WAS
TN
IAND ITS HISOS B ASND THE
GEELRA HSHI TNKE' HSGOM CIN
RFO ART COUISYES V BITUTHE T
Y
ID DNDNOW AE HAVRI D ASNKND
SH
IT'SVE OR.RND AHE T HNEAI SD
NLTNO O IYS IVE OR BUT WLIL
REOUEAC Y YIT WHROU
NES.
THHOAN M W RNTREEPSEED THE
ESTIANTH E OISFINRYVETH
YWOOSE HDENL RNTREEPSE.ED
A IHESN ICTELNTLELUAISDE IALT
WH
UG TOHO HHTEOU CLDOL RESVE
ROETH PFEMBL OOD M WNERFAARRE
AN
IDSEN STE HOMND ALA REPDCE
BY ALRU BTAI- ANT ICTELNTLELUA
NUOLND A BTS-OAN HDSN
TAIAICNHO W WLILEUR PSU A
GARWA AAPSTIN JHO WANITNYUT A
MOL CT.FLONIC
NAGAI IREDIUCYBL SLSSCEFU
ANDK LOOIL MARITY LDEEAR.
SOAYHE W HES I ONAP J
IKETASCCONT AHANTOU WST I
BE
NGVIDELI TIT WH JHEET
ST
AMRE.
>> JHEETEA STR I A
ITCONDOWNIO N NEL WLHAOW T
T
TSAYSSREHE I A PLEROWFUIN WD
TH
CL CATIRESHE T ETHAR 2
-PMILER-HEROUIN WDND AES MOV
HEEROV TEOU CRSF O TR. YHEEA
HAP TNEPEDEO BVE ORAP J
HAND DOWID A BBOMIT WHNY A
IOECPRISN ANDHE TN TOAV H AE
TAFNDWI OIL00 2 M PESERR HOU
M 4OR00ERESIL PR. HOU
Y IDFOU FLYAYID SEWS ITAS W
IM
LESSPOIB FHE T SYATTREG
FO
SE TRHO CONDIONTIS.
L WIILOT N FLY00 2T F00EE
WH J TEHETRET S IMEAS WLIL
YFL LOWND AHE TNNL OYLY FT
NIIN DTUR D TGHEAYHE TYL WIL
KETAE MP UR O PKICE M OFFND A
TAUTE M O OFHE T YR.EA
F ILYT AHT NIGND A LOWHE TN
TH
EY CNOANT SEE MEUT B TNHE I
EENCA SY MTAR TGE SO I WLIL
APEUS NM.AL
S T>>HINS I A ADE.
MYEORAVIT IIN LENHE TK BOO
IWHENES CTOMO T THEET J
ST.AM
GUYHO DRECOISVED IT HIS
REASCHAR WOT NYID WEL KNO
WN
USBECAE HEUB PSHLIEDOS MT OF
IT.
TEAU[LGHR]
SOHE T GUY WHOS I ATEA ZLO AND
REATTH PRENTVE PNNTSE O - -
TEEVPREN R TDHEFTES O THE
DWORL BUTHE TK BOOS I FLULF O
DE
SCILIOULET DAIIKET. THA
SOEOPL AEREIN FLYNDG U TERHE
JE
EA STTRY VMEROW L AND AT
ITTGH WIS CHANRSTE OFAL NAPM
NGOPDRPIVELL A OHER T THTLY
JCKPAEDEANAPESS.IT CIE
WHNSAP HPE.UI QCK
>>APTHA HSNSPE I THE TYNUR
IKYTOONONT ANONF IERN I A
TTERNUF  OMIS.TE
UREYTH BN DNOWQU6 1 S MEARESIL
OF
AOK TYO ONDNEIG NHTHE T
Y
BURNO TEA DTH06 600OU HHEN
PTHELANTAI PURSNE T BDNEKAC
TONELUA O - -UA GMAD H TOE B
FU
DGAMITEECAU THENGUR BNI
HUSH FNLAHTE SNCAS WO S
POOVER.RIWENG
ONHEF O TIEEA DDL NIGS O
FA
IARRFEAN HNUMIS HRY.
TANDSTHA IHE T ENDF O THE
HEOKBO W I TLELHE TE TALF O
WHNEAP HPED TTHA NHTIG.
SOEN W TTOAP JAN ANDEN W TTO
TH MUSEVMEU DOEDOT T TTHA
NI I ITT OSNEF THEOS MT
MO
NGVI ENCERXPIEES.
JU
B TSTOEURRODEDY B
OSMEMENTF TSBLER TRIE
INTHGHA T WTASON DE ONHA T
TNI
T.GH
EDAN HTAS WN'
ON DE.
HE OEN WT T TNOHERUM SME OF5 4
APTO NNDMAL AUR B TDNEO THE
NDOUHE T 66STAR LGEAN JAPEESR
WTICIESHEHIT TEP EXCONTIF
O.TW
IMROHISH N AANDIASAGAK
HI H
AVHE S FEDORERNO ATHE TYP O
BO
.MB
STHO:ET L'SET G T THE
TESTRANDCGI A DOR MALIOCUISSS
NB
ATT OUTH
S TTHIHAS I WW BTLEE MWA AY.
IAN'TIN FD ITN IOOHE T B
ITD REAT IAL T TKOY ME WIFKBU
NLASTHTIG I 1N486AP J GANES
MALEY AAL MET.
HEATWH T
EL HL?
AIEXPLT TNHAO TE M.
THE JEANAPESOW H TYHEHO CSE
TO
IAEM MORZELIHA WTPE HAPDNE
IN 1594N WHEHE T WYEEREDED RUC
TO RBLUBEIT WHS TON OFAP NMAL
PEDROP BDYRSOM BBE.
THMUS MEU NS IOTN AIAFF OICL
SEMUUMS I JTUS ASE HOUN O THE
SI
EE SDETR ITSUY GID DECENED T
SYEARHEGO A T SULDE B
SO TINTHGEM ROEMHARBE WT
HA
EDEN.
JTHEEANAPESER WE NOTAG EER TO
LDWEL ONHE TND E OFHE TAR W
AN
NEIER WEEER W BY THEAY W
ECABEUS TT' ISARLYRU HOD T
FIND ANYONEN MTIF O JEANAPES
CI T IESNHEME SUM 4R5.
EV
YBOD WANODTE T MEOV ON.
THEAY THEESAP JANEOV MEDN O
WH IEM LAYHES THI CEF OF
AAFSTF TTHE AIROR F WCECH
IS
ERNO ATHORXT ERA FNADIRYTAC
P OATNENNTOI I THE BKOO I
HEEDST T PIV FEPLEOEN IHE T0t 2h
CRYTU ANGIL CIVNSIA
HIER WAS TEEHRUL PT PLAR IS
URRFO CAYSTI MS FE.IV
T WSOHANEAP HPE IDS HE WAS
EDOMPROTND A BYFKAK MES HIM
FADHE OHE T AIR FCEOR.
HSOEAS WH BOTOI APP HEDNTDEA
TOFHEIR ACE FORND A GENIV A
ME
L, T HIGETSTHE MT TALHA
GOVE DMERNNT BPIESTENGEI THE
FTFIH MTOS MURRODEUS
URCENTY.AL 2 TNHEh0t
TUT BOTELE EVA THERG A
ET
HAIS TT WTHA HEID D AYUACTLL
SPEDER OTHEA DSTH.
WAR TO SREREHEFOAV SEDER OTHHE
S.LIVE
>> ATNES I O.
HETBU T IRESOM SETH TRU TO
NATTH IHE TCEBS AEN OFHE T
ICOMOM BBS AD LANNV IIOASNAT
OFYANAP BHE UTENIDSTA STE
ALHEY B T SIEOVTNI UONCH WHI
S PSED TOKTT AACOULD
ESVEHA R ITEULDASN CSLTUAIE
EV GATREERHAT HDPEAPNE
OVHE TRUM SME5. 4
THAT.E N'SOBT DOU AUTBO
HSOE WTENUE ROG INHE T SMEUMR
WATCNGHI HIMS A HEOU WLD HIT
HEOTRIT CYE HLD WOUUS JT
BUN DEDOWAN JAPEES CIEITS
TTEAFRMI AHETO BOM
HEID DTN'TO SPH WITIR H
HIA
NANDIASAGAKE H IS SLLTI
SE-2GIN BL F9SULF OMAP NAL
BURN DNOW JEANAPESSIT CIE
FR
OM GM.UA
KI'VEFDIN O GEONFF O THEEE DP
END.
I>>SESNT IERALNGTI TONGKI T
YOOW N.
EN ID REAHE T BKOOND A
TNIFISHK BHEOO IUG THOHT, IS
HEISTH TIW ANTARK? BOO
I>>TS INY FUN.
WHS IT? I
IITS BKOOBO AUT SO MYAN
DIENERT TNGHIS.
IT
OIN KD IS.
ITUN F HNYOWRNS AWE THE
ONESQUTIUT B TYHEAD H A
SANVCOERHEONTI T OERTH DAY
WITH AUY GT A TAN RD
ATRPCOORHONIO WEDAD H L A
AMWARGENT IDEEND SOHA W
T
ENHAPP N IEDFORTHOR K WEAAS
FATE SEDTA TND AYHEEDOD MEL
IT
.
H WDE TO SURECELL A THE
EANUCLE WRERNSEA WPONTUR CRELY
?HELD
FHE TYURIGEDUT O THEOS M
T
ISSOPHCATE WAYHEND A T
ERANSWS I IST' A KDINE W
SN'VETNNEE I 75 YRSEAN IA
ISTHRYOU CNT
SSO IES MAKNIFG AHAANST LKOO
LIAL A W IKNHE TK. PAR
T WSOHAS IHE TAK T
HOE-ME
ONLESS
D SEYAIUPT I S TSEPOD A BOE
REOERND TEEO PPLN ITH NOR
KO I AAND WNTOHIASNGT TNHA
YO
UL SUHO DDOUTBS AOLYEL
HIEREVYT INGNR YOUOW PERO T
DAVOIHISVENT.LIUATY
YOOTO D N TAN WTOSHI T
HA.EN
ASATTH WOIIS H P INTTS I A
SSME.
IAND IN KDF O FLEE LEIKE W
WAYS TEE NDEO B RDINEMDEF O
ATTH FAC
ATTH THEDE IA OFHE T
STMIADNITIRAONAS W AHI TNK
WSHAS WAYOR WSEHA TNMP TRU.
ELLARGYAU BEC O THE
CAAYERLI WENE H WTO T W.AR
TH
D NEYEEO TE BIN REMD.DE
DON GOO T WART A THERO DP
H AOFATH WIT A BEEN IR YOU
.NNBOET
ASHE W ARU B NLTATYASESUS BINS
S GITOEN O WAY LGERN THAOU Y
KTHINTND A I FCEORSOU YO INT
DALSMLNSISECIOONOU Y DAN'T W
T
AKTO M
NEE TOE BDEEM RIN
ODF
.THAT
SOOOSHI BK MAYE B IS A
NDOUTHSAOO BKSO TEM R YDINOU
DOT WTANOOOW DNHI TS
TH.
SONC OOUE YUY B THE AIO
P TDHENTRIEDONDI ETI OF THEAN
BOIA MERAFABVA AILAY TLEOD
IFREOU A ITEERNTES IDNT WHA
MA IOLLCMKI TSALUT ANGBO I
AGCOENUR T YEOUK LOOOT A A
BOHI I T INKST'DAL CLE
WORSTIC BARYER ROBEP CTRE
ER
SIT I AKIK TTO HOWHE T BHUS
ADTISTNIRAT WONENO TAR
WIESNT IERBONGTI AT TUTHA
BOOWS I H IST'LE FUEYD B
IDSM PEDLINE O - -ND BLI
UPSTIDISDE IALM BUT ISOR ME
TLPOINS?ES
IISTVI INEBLTAE?
T INKHIHE TRERE AIMES
WWHEN HEADO T GOO T WAR
BEHEEUS TERMA SAI WDE
DIE H'TAVE.HO CIC
>>IN ANDGAST THEAP JESANE.
>>HAO W CTICHOEID D WEAV HE?
AN AHE TREREIOCC OAS INS
HK INWEOEAV NE.HO CIC
DTBU IONK THIHA TTE W SULHOD
TRRAR HDEOREVE TNTMHEND A
PE
WAPRHSD NEEE AAY WOW H TO
MLIVEAREOR C BULEFLY WOREFEE
PLGE IONTHE T.SE
ONF OHE T PCAODSTT THA WE
SKEMA I THESO EPIDEKI TALONG T
THSHRI BTIVENV IOLNT I
ISGHAFANNNTA IHE T9t 1h
CE
IURNTY ISTS IUR ABSD.
IS A CZYRANOT NIOHA T YTOU
SE
E SNDOMSRO TOPNT IO
AFNISANTA ANDUB SEDUHE TM
ANVE E SBORYDYSAYSHA TT' NOT
PO
.IBSSLE
BU WHE TYAREER WOTDNE N TO DO
IT BUT TN TO SEEHE T
SIDECI G TONOO TOAR WIT W THHE
BRILHIS MARITYLIAT BTAON
ETHERS I ASE SENT THAT' ILL
TINGOG BOEAI STRWATFGHOR.RD
D I NEV IERS
IGSTRAARFOHTRW
>> SO TKIALNGBO AUTOM S OEF
THNTNC EOUOUSER YAV HEH WIT
SMBMEERF OAY TOD'SARIL MITY
AN
O ODNEFHE TNG THIS I LEIK
ABHI TSOO BKO S ARE G
AT
SERV IEN TIT MHEILY.ARLEOEHO W
TDAN I MNKHIYAN OF USHAT
FHAVESLIEENGBO AUTAR WHA TT
AR
TI CERIFLCA OHO TSE OFS U
AVOWH HOU EENC TERNTEDHE
DUDIINVIHOSAL W ARENGER SVI
E AATREDIRAXTORNDRYNA A OFTH
-EON - IUAIVNDIDL WH AN
EDINCRROLEIB G H OUPFANUM
GSBEIN
W NDOWE HEAVHE TBI BOMNG
AL
IKSTMO L TEHEOMBE MIAAF
PA TWOHA TT WEON D H'TEAV
BO
MBIT SES.
AOMPUNRTE I FNTRO OF ME
ANI CD SEN AOM BBNT IO A
BCKPILE IREARL ANM ROO
WHSOMEEER OS.RSVEEA
IATSHE TRE DAM SOHA WT ARE
NFETH UNESOREEQUON CSE
CEENS
ANT WDHAHES I TATEM TPTNIO
WI THO TSE OLSOOFREAR WFA?
TI W>>RIS TNGHIK BOO IAD H
DIH WERIT CHE TEFHIF OFF STA
HEOF T F AIR
CEOR.
ERFORM OHI CEFF SFFTA.
WHEASNGIT STI INIS H BDKYACAR
WI
B ATHCHUNF O HISEN S
RIO
ERLEADNIPSH IOU YROR F.CE
HEESAS DGIBCRINO TE M THE
ENFFDIERER GENIOATNS OF
IVFEEFCT OESENSCI PFREONSI
BO
INMBG.
IFEB SOMYODDAN WTEO TE TAKT I
HEYN I M BDKYACARHEY'
THAVEB BOOMHE THO WLEE BAS
THENIE VAMTN YOUAK TE OUTHE T
STET AN THELO C OSEFH O
YO
E TUAKOWN THE.OU HSE
T NDOWYHEOU CLDT JUSAK TN
E
MEUT O.
VEDAN EGTHRYIN ILS EE LSTEF
NGANSTDI
NEHE T O TAN HDLLTHA A
SOW
TYOUIG FHTAR W WSHITNGIL KLI
A
OOT LFENNN IOCTEOPLUTE B
HEHEEAD T OIOBVUSOI PNT IT
TKEMASIS DHEECONIO TO GO T
WA
ER VYAS E AYNDAY M BOOE T
EA.
HEIN TEOU CRS OFNG DOIHI T
S
IBOOKE HAVNO E ROURMSPEESCT
M TRHEYITILARRSEA LDENPHI IFO
OUISTH COMRYNT SCR DEESEIB MY
OKBOT THA MCOALLMASBO A
UT
LHISFFEOV AITRAI W THHEIR A
FO
E.RC
HADAN T A ITSELOLBSUTE. TYRU
TEAU[LGHR]
W IWASSLW AAYTI PAROAL T
ATHECE FIROR TOE BON HTES BUT
MI A INLL AF OHE TSEE.EO PPL
EY A NREOTNS IVESIENTI.
ATHEY ARELL TWA ARE.
TANDORYHE WEAK R HYLLDARO T
MA
E SKEURE WON D'TL FALNT IO
ATTHRA T WPHIT THEDI CONONTI
THARIL MITIS DYECNS A
MADEY BIT POLALICER INTEREFENC
ATTHN I CONIOLTSUATH WNIT
GTALIRYHISUY W ICHNOM SEMI
T'YSWA ISERNO ATH BKOOH WIT A
TEADGRUAAREM SINOLN I PICITAL
RYTHEO BUT WEON D H'TEAV
LTILICAECO T D MIOISNSYEAD B
MI
TALIRY PPLEOE.
AAV HEOT L OFUE QIOSTNS
NGCOMIN I.
AREOMINNG I LEIKBS BOM
AINKL PICELAR BRE.
NONGOO LKI IT AAMTANSGRUT B
TH
ST QEUEOMNSIO CGINN. I
SISTH IAS FNATI.
ITHIS ASRE G QATNSTUEIOAN C
YO MAL TK AEORUTBOHE T
SE
DWHY YOOUHI T TNKHES.
IDLGILOCAREIF DFEESNC
NTWBEEERAHE T B SHENCSPWHO U
SO SCANIIGFILYNT INLA P OSCE
PRSWOHI.UI QCK
>>NSSHI I BELANYNTLLRIIA
BOOR FVEGI ME IE HAV
TERGFOOT N TNHEFEAM O THEOO BK
AN
D THE AHOUTR A TDUSHOAN
IEOLAPOGSUT BE'S A PALITOLIC
SC
WNCIEE FKIORNG TORHEAN RD
ATRPCOORNNIO I THEEN SEVESTI
RODAN W ATENRE INC BBLDIE
KOO
EDCALLASHE T MKSF OR FOUT I
AWASUT ALLBOHE TARIO
US
CHBRAN T OESFHE ANRIMECA
RYLIMITA THERM AYND AAV NYND A
AI
CE FRORUT HE MESAKN A
DFHOFAN IOI PNT TNHEK BOOHA TT
I WUGHOHTASOIU GENOUS Y
UALLANERNDST D TDHENCFEIFRE
EE
EETWN THECEER SVIOOS LTK A
CTHE APEHALT THE ADECAMYO S I
TORAHE T T DINNOW IEE S WT
IINPOT TNHET WESOI P CNTPEHAL
ISHI GOTC ANDRA G GYNIRATE
MOYOSTRITOE D'TSNOO L LKEIK
ITOU CLDURVI ATIR DEC
BEACLRNDSTLA AOO LKE LIKT I
WA IUI BLT8N 1RYEN CTU ANDT I
OKLOSIK LE ITEP RSSERENTHE T
YSKUE ARGDRADISTONTI,
NH
ECCONNITONTI W L THHENDDAN A
ON ANDN O THE NYAVHA C ILPEN
POANNASLIKS LOO LEIKT' IS OUT
OFTA ILYRA GNDLA G ASSND
RBLEND A AUG HEE DOMND A AND
HEENTH TAV NY HAS TSHI
GROSDIEER INTALTINAONIS VNIO
THLLO G A AUNROD WHE T
LD.
ATHEY TREHEOS MTEEC SUR
CHBRAN N OO CAN TCHOUM THE
HETHWI TT FSEASHI S.PS
THS I THE NYAV.
STHATYEBOMODUBAS H RHEDBE T
GR T OSNHEHHU CRC EVE WAY
REBEFOCEER SVI
IATSHE T NAVUT B THEIR A
RCE?
T WATANO TUI RN ITUT B I
WODRANC EOUGE EDYRYVEBOO T
OGONR YOUHO PNE ANDEOO GGL
ORRAI F ADECAMYLHA CPEND A
YO
L WUILEE SLYXA ECTT WHAS I
TAGINUT ABO.
>> SOMNE WHOID DHA TT
S TNTOONECDHAT MIOOTN WASWA
THEUA VISLIS DAYPLO S WHYO D
YO THI TNK ISEHOICOLDEOGAL
ENFFDIERSCEHO S OWFFIR THE?
>> CABE CEUSPEHALSN I THE
TRADIONALER UNDNGANSTDIHE T
IROLEYS PTLAN I THEVI SERCE
AC
EMADYHE W TREHESAL VUE ARE
ESREPR ATEENDT WNDHAOU YTA SND
FORN I THEAM SE WAYOU YOOK
ATFE DIFNTREHE T CTUULREF O
TWITHSEHONIEN MNOSTE ANDHE T
MA
RITEALOS PNSSSSEIO AND
HI
ICARERCHALEOPLE.
IK'SIT L AEHT LIGOO WNDE B.OX
AN CHA TT GAPHIOTCDRAT CHE
ALI
SE TTHHO S.RAPILS
HOFOWO TRO APPHAC
LIITIRUATY THE SEAMAY THE
PE B WLEHOLTUIHO TSEPE CHALS
O TERYHE WLD BEUIHOGIN TSE
ELCHAPSOR.
>> YOUTI WRI YNG
OU
LESEAMALLYSS BETCEAN DOLSAI T
UN C TCKHEERRAHACTH WSITHE T
OV
INARERCHTE CGONUAXTL
USDISCONSI.
C TDOHEERRAHACT T PSERHEA IDE
THHES I TON CLXTTEUARNAT PTE
LE
D TADORICOISVE TNGHE
CHTEACRS?
'R Y>>OUESKINGE M TO
RET?EC
AY ME B ATL LITITE B OF
BO.
ORXT ERA CNADIRYERRAHACTND A
NS WHT. I
ND TNHEHI TSK BOO IO D
FA
L ILLNEOVIT WH THE
RSACARTE A ANDLL ID NEE TO
DO TASO CCTSTONRU A
NA
E.ATRRIV
HETBU T TNOAL TKBO AUTO T SEE
HEIF TE WYERTI SLL AVELI.
>> INTHKY THERE A SLLTIN I
CO
TIERNVSA.ON
>> ATWH YOUHI TNKSUR CTIAY LEM
HEDAN T BBEOMRIA MAF WIT
THKF O DNEROS.UI QCK
>> ONELD WOUAY S TT'HASY
VI
ONSI.
N TDHEOU WLDAY SIV G MEE A
NDOUTHSA.
[LTEGHR]
>> .
I>>IL W SAYHI TS O.NE
TARETHREHE OPIER EDESF
ONVIRESINETIS O - -
SIREVIISONT H YTOISRY
OFGHOUT DIXP EAN T INGNHETH
BO
?OK
N TDHEO TGL GOOHEE T AIR
EFORCPE CHALIT WT! THHA
IICWHH TSHERO APP
IAPRTE
ONRESPSEO T TTHA.
EV A RIOISNN O - - A
SIREVIISONT HTOISRYND AN THE
ASTO FGONHIINNT IOKS BOO.
A>>NDNE ESOPIDEOT DEVED
WIHA TTIS REVNIIOSTIS HRYTO
HEDAN TR ONVE THEOU CERSF O
TH
T NEEXEA YR.
ISAND  SOER INT.TIESNG
AN THE TN ROLIEAZEHI TS IS
ETH BNGINEGNIF OLL REAOOY GD
IN
INRETESTT PGARF TK. BOO
A>>NDHE TN TOUR T INTNT IO
EITHRWN O.
>>UT B NHIOTNGVE ERES COM OF
.IT
>>HIHE T ANGUTBOOLLYOD
AVEYTH HAS IEDE BUTHE T ANERFT
ALE WHIY THERE A YNGOU BUT
YTHEN GOUETAD J.ED
E H>>ERS I THEUE Q OIOSTNRVE
YO
HT RURIGHOULR IS A
ERPOSTHATS THE
ICGNSIIFFCEAN OHE TMO ATUN
POERN O -AS┘-DH.
>> IND FOUT I OINNLET I WAS
URKELI M RREDERS OOWF T
ALLTCUUROL REV
IOUTN.
ETO B A GD BO.SS
GH[LAUR]TE
TEAU[LGHR]
HESO T YREOUO. G
>> .
A>>ND THEIT WHN THEOU Y SEE
TH
YEREI EDE WSANWANGRI AYRO FM
MEND A TARDS THE PTEOSR
AB H MEYD.EA
KDAN I WWNOTHAHE TY ARE
NGINTHKI.
HEDAN TRE TNHEH S'SUC AEGRET
BU IHA TT ASAYLWS MYOR FAV
ET
NTMOMEF ONY AER INTEWVI.
A>>ND Y ARE?OU
REUYO A AAN C BIAADNUTHA TT IS
ETHAT GAYEWRU DG.
>>HATHA W YTOU'T CAN SEE
PAINNGTISM FRO THEEW NK YORH
TYCIT.AL BLE
BU WHE TNHITUR MRODEUS
DIORATS.
HE>> T IRES A WLEHOHI TNG
ING ONIK L AEELNSLND AAY LEM
LLDAN AHA TT.
N TDHE AO TSKE SOMUE Q
IS
EAS WRA WP UP I WLILSK A YOU
DFRAPIEIRIOUE QST.NS  . . ..NERR
HEWAI TCDSSUC SCENIO ANDHE TN
LIKE FY,RUEBAR P NOCET ASDEERMB
HWEIT AAL WL.
KNN'DOT .OW
EDCAI LLY M.GE ANT
WHRE AOU YIS LNITENG TO, A
NO
OASDCTSIO ARUDHAT YOUER W
I
GENSTINHAO T TSMAT KET I
ELCOMP
NGLI.
A.
>> O AWEREHEN TP CUS O TFHE
FSAYPLOF
N IS LTE ATO LOTBI OF
LLSI
RONMMSHTIGOW NND SILAR
BA TBAETLL CMEHED ATEONNT
ND
EPAREL MEDYSFOF R THE GNDRA
OFENEVT HE TPR SG.IN
>>DANHO W D YE, HAVT WHAS I
YOCTRE PDI ENIOTAS AND WT?
ON I>> D'TAV H. OENE
WH
O.NO KWS
>>M PCHED THA TTAR WHEIZ
S
MGHMITHEEAK TFFLA PYON ESVE
THGH WEAV HE AEC RDOR --
YO>> W KUNOHE TY AREOI G TNGO
EN
DLY BAD.
>>LWIT ADSS AYENLY BADT THA
YO GVEOT AUY GIK LES THIHA TT
T-F 6OOHR TEEIT W EIG
UNREBO.DS
AT LEMEOU AIN FALUE QIOSTN.
MI' GNGOI TOIVEHE T AEIEUDNC A
LFINA QNSTUEIOHEND A TNCUD AIE
I
LNAUE QIOSTN ICH WSHIRYIS HTO
SBOOKO D YOU THONKHI SD ULBE
SENTLIA R?DIEANG
GI AS UPL COUKS BEOOHA TT
U
HINTHKFFEAV ATEECD YOU AS A
,ITWRERTO SERTERYLLNK T,HIER
YTHATNK TOUHISTH OER
F  OS
WODULEF BENIT FM.RO
AHA WT QN.STUEIO
ERTHUSSE' JT SY. MOAN
WHOLD WOUN E IVEIN BEGO TAY S.
EN DITEP ODSNT WHAOU Y ARE
IN
EDRETEST IN.
ARERTHE E SEOM VTNIEAM B-KSOO -
T'LESUS FOC ONIE VAMTN- -HA W
DOOU Y OHI TNKTHF EHI TSNGHA TT
R
ERI CAR IEDNONIC FTIY BIM T
O'
IEBRN.
>>ILD WOUUTBS AOLAYYEL SHA T
TS
ODS  AGOS ANY A.
OUOBD VIYSL YOU'T CAN GO
HEYWREIT WEAUTHO R
NGDI.
IHI TNKHA TAU [TINBLDIE]
EA>> RY.LL
>> IT JSUSAN F.STTAIC
YON'CAT BE AR RI WTE
OF
TINFNOIC AONNDOT N.
BTHATKOO JS IE T USONRFO T
ESAG.
>> AINOM T SOUR SE.
ERTHEERRE A VFEY WTE WRI.RS
ALPEESCIFI NLYON WIOCTNTERIRS
DO SS THI IS A NHAEAM TWET
OWKNN EVEER AFTIS H TGIRAC
DE
H.AT
HEAD A ILA PCEHEN T LEIF OF
ID TS,HE CATVEONRSNDNIO A I
WINTHKEOU WGRLD AT TEEHAOU Y
ARIKE L THA AS WL.EL
YWHATOU CEOM OUT WSHIT I
IMTRTPOANND A IT GSETEEO PPL
TAG ABTND AET GSAD DTOS
BOINBRG SOK T TIN DHEINM RGOO
TA SANE DAY DIDOU YNO KSO -W-
WE TNKHA YOR FGROU YR TEA
RICONT ATIBUONNDOR FS THI
TEICIFK. BOO
I EOP HERYBO GSET A OOP CY
T
.
THKOROU Y FNGOS HTI
IF W YOUTAN AT LAS WT'D,OR I
YO
S.UR
>>EE NDO TOI P I ONTUT D'TON
TH B MKYTHROERAS HEA RD ANY O
MYOO BKSE UT B HSHAD REAFLL A OF
YOUR BKSOO.
ON TOFHESHI TNG LE' WVE
D
HEREHOS I WAS W SHE TRTMAER
WEGLAD BLL.THROER
>> HETAIL WL UT ALKBONOU Y I
A
WAY TAKTHA MESSO ME USEA JLO.
HELILAL TKBOUTNOU Y I AAY W
OUKELI Y AHIRE TS,ND AOURE A
KI
TH ONDF EEL INTCTUA
HE'TOE DSNANEA RD HIYTNG EEPXCT
IBNA[IUD]LE
OKBOS.
TH ATS I ASAOL COSLTA MIS.KE
OU EINCVEGERA E HBORYDYOEER T
PIP U AOPYF OHE T B
BEOR
A MAFIRETWHHES T I INT PINRIR O
O.DI
YMAKENK TOUHIND AT IVE IS RY
ENRTAING.
YOANTHK U, M.COALLM
R,ATHEHE TAC BKO Y.OU
HA>> TNK YOU SOT BH.MUO CH
THAI VE I SOAYM A ATL LITE
BUEDMMHA TT I'T DONWHNO KW  TO
.DO
TOUTHGHAY MAS IBE WNG GOIO T
GEOM SNFE IONMAORTIUT B YOU
CA IGET T. ATLL
GLAD TLLWE,NKHASO TRY EVEE ONIN
THCEDIAUENOR FOI JNGNIS. U
INETH LPU TKO  IHARCSES T INHE
CH BOXND AE WRE ALI-M EAI
NGV
YOERNE ASL. WEL
SEPLEA BOM CENDKAC AEE S US FOR
EMOREANNTVES CK CDHE OUTHE T
NDCALE.AR
HEENWH TIM TE CESOM,E WTAN CNO
WAELO T WOUMECO YAC BK TOHE T
NGILBUDI.
THTIUNL ,EN TAK CARE,Y STA
E
HAAND